Paramount R allegedly planning a voyager
reboot this rumor has been knocking
around for a while and has had a lot of
interest in the last week or two but is
it true welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
this has been a question that's been
asked oh God at least for a couple of
years that will there be a voyager
reboot a kind of like Picard season 3
event where we all see a lot of the
actors we'll get to see chicote January
7 of 9 tovok etc etc return for a
reprise or series now I don't think when
people say we're going to get a voyager
reboot they genuinely mean you know Kate
Mall Group Janeway captain of the new
Voyager even though we have seen the new
Voyager in
um Prodigy and a couple of other things
but I think they do mean sort of a
Picard season three type of thing now
very very recently just within the last
few days giant freaking robot
have released a story saying that this
is 100 happening that they are trusted
and reliable sources have told them that
they are planning over a pyramid a
voyager reboot so is that true
at the moment there are lots of things
going on at Paramount and secret hideout
the company that the produced Star Trek
there are lots of different decisions
being made we apparently recently had
Starfleet Academy green lit even though
if you're a regular Star Trek you'll
know I recently did a video that puts
question marks over that project we
believe we're going to be getting
section 31 if secret hideout and
kurtzman can get Michelle yeoh to agree
one of the most in demand actresses in
the world right now
that kind of struggle
but if they could get it to do a mini
series or something we still make it
section 31. there is a lot of talk about
maybe Star Trek and Legacy a follow-on
from Picard season three carrying on the
Voyages of the USS Titan a with seven of
nine and maybe Captain Shaw
now that is the project that most Trek
is if you ask them seem to want when I
actually did a poll asking if you were
going to scrap basically Starfleet
Academy now to get Star Trek Legacy
would you and almost everybody said yes
but why is this Voyager rumor so popular
it really started because Kate McGrew
agreed to do Prodigy and that katemal
grew as janeways appeared in a couple of
different Star Trek things over the
years as Admiral January she was
obviously in a couple of the Star Trek
movies briefly and that really kept the
rumor mill going that obviously katemal
grew or loves the character she goes
loads of Comic Cons and things as
January she seems to really enjoy
meeting the fans she she really does
love the character So that obviously led
to the rumor that obviously she's going
to return at some point she's one of the
most popular captains we've ever had in
the chair and you know actually she's
the launcher of a million memes over the
whole coffee thing but I actually think
that is the main reason why we would as
fans love to see her as well she was a
popular captain
seven of nine then returning for Picard
continued those rumors Jeri Ryan has
been massively popular in a reprisal of
the role and that is one of the main
reasons again why we all want to see
Legacy that is the series we actually
want to see Paramount stop letting
secret hideout do this crap we don't
want to watch okay
Legacy please and they got your code to
reprice's role for Prodigy and then
again a brief cameo in Picard season
three all of these things leave down one
road don't they well giant freaking
robot believe so because they're trusted
and reliable sources they'll never get
anything right they're like monkeys a
joke but this is what you have to
realize they're like monkeys at the zoo
throwing poo if they just randomly throw
enough poo eventually they'll hit
something and that's basically what
giant freaking robot do they throw poo
until they hit something in this case
they have missed
I do actually speak to trusted sources
in Hollywood I actually do speak to a
lot of people that work in and around a
lot of different aspects of Hollywood
one actually works for one of the
biggest talent agencies in Hollywood I
asked him about this and they said look
we know that this has been talked about
because over at secret hideout they have
talked about virtually everything a
couple of marketing people I speak to
say they know that a voyager type thing
like Picard season 3 has been pitched at
Paramount by secret hideout because
they've pitched lots of things Alex
kurtzman actually says himself we've got
loads of ideas on how we would love to
develop the Star Trek universe and they
do discuss these ideas with Paramount
but almost none of them will ever get
made
they are just banging ideas around and
some of those ideas may not become TV
series but they may eventually become
part of another TV series for example
they maybe talk about a voyager reboot
and then the executive might go well we
really loved Jerry Ryan the seven of
nine we'd love it if we could bring her
back
well we're thinking about doing this
Picard series why don't we put seven of
nine in Picard that's how some of these
decisions get made one idea gets pitched
and it leads into another idea now the
main reason why we know the giant
freaking robot story is not true because
they've said that this series is
actually in development which we know is
not how Paramount do things now you do
have a couple of different things when
it comes to developing a TV series you
now have very early development where
they don't announce it they bounce the
ideas around they talk about what they
want to do they maybe get a production
company on board if they haven't already
got one in Star Trek obviously they do
they do things like that so I talk about
Stargate a great deal and the god
eventual Return of the series they are
in that early period of development
they're thinking about what they want to
do lots of ideas get knocked around and
then eventually somebody high up makes a
decision and signs a piece of paper and
the show gets green lit then it goes
into development now that is when
scripts get written and the studio
actually starts spending money on the
project lots of scripts get written the
scripts get Banks back to the executives
over at Paramount in this case they will
put a few ideas on Bounce scripts back
they will develop those then they start
looking at casting in the Voyager case
that would be relatively easy because
you bring the main characters back
there's only four or five of them that
really could return so you get the story
idea you get the actors on board you
then start the real work of thinking
about where we're going to film all the
business stuff the budgets and all that
sort of thing even though pre-budgets
will have been arranged much earlier but
anyway
that is how the development process
works and then about six to nine months
after that after it gets green lit if
you're lucky you start filming now
the fact that giant freaking Robert have
said this is in development we know is
100 not true because Paramount will have
announced it if it was Starfleet Academy
has not actually gone into development
yet it's in that process now they've
done the pre-stuff they've talked about
what they want to do very Loosely now
they'll start writing scripts now
they'll start the actual development
process
Parliament would have announced this is
a voyager reboot about to get announced
no
is a voyager reboot in development
now
but there is an interesting little
sidebar on this because I have heard
rumors that secret hideout are looking
at a Star Trek Legacy type project
they want staff at the Academy they are
trying very very hard to get section 31
and they might actually be in trouble
with the studio because they may have
made promises about section 31 that
they're now struggling to keep and
basically they've got Starfall Academy
on those promises so let's see how that
works out over the next few weeks
but the next plan for them is to do some
sort of Star Trek Legacy idea according
to a couple of the people I speak to now
we've already had hints of this a little
bit because people like Marina certis
Gates McFadden have actually sort of
basically tweeted that this has already
been discussed Patrick Stewart has
actually said that this might not be the
end of Picard and he might return for
another mystery project well I can tell
you the mystery project is being looked
at and if we're going to get a voyager
reboot it might be a part of that
project it will not be a voyager reboot
but maybe shakote would return for a
bigger party rockers the captain we know
he is we've seen him sat in the
captain's chair in Picard season three
even though he is actually a changeling
now and might be dead there is actually
an important bit in Picard season 3
where seven of nine is talking to two
vacant tuvak then obviously becomes a
chain slink and she actually says well
two of up must still be alive for you to
know that because he must have told you
that is basically a big hint that tuvak
isn't dead and that we might see him in
the future
people I've been talking to saying that
they would love over a Paramount to do
this big sort of TNG Voyager maybe even
a couple of DS9 active sort of event
series
and that they are really pushing secret
hide out to do that but apparently Alex
kurtzman is waking to do section 31 and
staffley Academy and is actually being a
little bit resistant to the idea the
fans want Terry matalis to run that show
and apparently Alex kurtzman is also
quite resistant to that idea
but I'm going to do a video where I'm
going to talk about why aren't we
getting Star Trek Legacy that will be
available in the next few days
and I'm going to talk about a few rumors
about Alex kurtzmann that don't paint
him in the best light
but guys I'd love to know what you think
about this rumor about Star Trek Voyager
reboot is it a load of nonsense or is it
actually maybe
partly true which I actually suspect it
is but the giant frequent robot have no
clue about that I'd love to know exactly
what you're thinking get into the
comments as always if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack wherefore a
small contribution each month you get to
see most of our videos on behind the
scenes stuff etc etc before everybody
else
as always please stay safe enjoy Star
Trek and I'll see you later
[Music]